this is the sky news leaders debate with
Adam Bolton rarely in political history
can three men have been tasked with
delivering so much in so little time
David Cameron Nick Clegg and Gordon
Brown a week ago no one could have
predicted how the TV outing would shape
the race tonight the leaders went into
battle with their eyes wide open if it's
all about style and PR count me out if
it's about the big decisions I'm your
man if you vote conservative you will
get a new team running the country I
think if we do things differently we can
be proud once again of the role we can
play as a force for good
one man's performance had electrified
the race and Nick Clegg had to prove he
is not a one-trick Wonder does it help
anyone in Bristol or anyone else in the
country for that matter David Cameron to
join together in the European Union with
a bunch of nutters anti-semites people
who deny climate change exists
homophobes that doesn't help Britain of
course we need to change the European
Union but you change clubs of which you
are a member by getting stuck in on
Europe defense and immigration it was
the end of mr. nice-guy
what would that be what you'd said the
cat what's the number ten million and
counted out the country even though it
would be more helpful if you would
support identity cards for foreign
nationals instead of opposing I'm just
asking for a simple honest answer to a
big question which is the man in the
middle is now a threat and the ones to
the side had to deal with him on his
resistance to Trident both sought to
portray him as simply naive I think it's
a real risk as the Liberal Democrats say
first to be opposed to an independent
nuclear deterrence say they do want one
but it's not the same as trying but they
can't tell us what it is you can't take
risks with this it's really a move right
I have to deal with these decisions
every day and I say to you Nick get real
get real because Iran you're saying
might be able to have a nuclear weapon
and you wouldn't take action against
them but you're saying that we've got to
give up our Trident somewhere else and
I'd get a weapon now you say get real
about the danger that we face Cameron
had much to prove tonight and we saw to
do it by repetition if I was your Prime
Minister
if I become Prime Minister if I was your
Prime Minister and
by portraying his party is the one that
now offers a real change but on set it
often sounded awfully like the same old
two-party politics those leaflets you've
been getting from labor those letters
you've been getting from labor are pure
and simple lies okay let me challenge
you will you withdraw the leaflets that
are going out around the country saying
that the Conservatives would take away
things like the free bus bus you know
you really should be ashamed of doing
the thing David David I have not
authorized any leaf looks like that what
I would ask you to say is why is it not
a new manifesto that you're keeping free
eye tests and free prescription charges
it must have been the longest 90 minutes
of their lives constantly aware of what
their strategists will have told them
look to camera be assertive attack the
other two so what's the verdict what
David Cameron showed tonight was real
conviction written in Europe and you
came from Mars and said which one's
Prime Minister it's pretty obvious than
one you'd say would be brought round
prime ministerial had substance and real
quality and leadership I thought and it
came across with passion with conviction
a very good communication of what are
more difficult subjects complex on
immigration and on defense and the early
polls backs those views each gotta
bounce making the race tighter than ever
back for more next week gentlemen
Michele turf at Sky News Bristol